hasta la cárcel de dandong en la
frontera con corea del norte el
embajador de canadá llegó en persona
para escuchar la sentencia de la
justicia china el canadiense michaels
pavor es condenado a 11 años de cárcel
por espionaje william condenamos
vehementemente esta decisión que fue
emitida después de un proceso judicial
donde faltaba equidad y transparencia
nuestros sentimientos acompañan a
michael y su familia en este periodo
difícil
el empresario fue arrestado en 2010 y
ocho días después del arresto de
vancouver que menguan su directora
financiera de huawei la hija del
fundador de la gigante compañía china
era señalada por eeuu de fraude bancario
en el marco de las sanciones
norteamericanas contra irán china no
dejó de pedir su liberación denunciando
una maniobra política
será que me cause pavor sirvió de moneda
de intercambio es lo que afirma a
washington que acusa a beijing de
utilizar seres humanos como maniobra de
negociación china por su parte desmiente
estas acusaciones la coincidencia en la
agenda es que la sentencia contra
michaels pavor es anunciada al tiempo
que se llevan a cabo las comparencias de
mengua en su frente al tribunal
canadiense para una serie de audiencias
que terminarán el 20 de agosto con la
decisión sobre su posible extradición
hacia estados unidos un día antes la
justicia china había confirmado en
segunda instancia la pena de muerte para
otro canadiense robert schellenberg
condenado por tráfico de drogas